zu gast ist heute der präsident des
robert koch instituts professor lothar
wieler der mann der zuständig ist für
die korona bekämpfung in deutschland wir
wollen uns heute darüber unterhalten was
es bedeutet dass die infektionszahlen
wieder so stark ansteigen
und wir wollen uns mit den argumenten
der kritiker auseinandersetzen
die sagen die krone maßnahmen seien das
ergebnis staatlicher history herzlich
willkommen bei phoenix persönlich und
engagiert bin froh dass ich bei ihnen
sein kann
professor lila die zahl der täglichen
neuinfektionen ist wieder über 6000
fälle angestiegen mehr als im frühjahr
wie dramatisch ist die situation
naja das eine ist die eine einzige zahl
also diese zahl von über 6.000 aber viel
wichtiger ist wahrscheinlich noch die
entwicklung die wir in den letzten tagen
sehen es geht ja wirklich seit zwei drei
wochen kontinuierlich nach oben
das heißt es ist eine sehr sehr
schlechte entwicklung und wir sollten
tunlichst dafür sorge tragen dass wir
diese entwicklung aufhalten können was
haben wir denn inzwischen gelernt was
ist der unterschied zwischen 6000 neuen
infektionen am tag im frühjahr und halte
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage also zum
einmal muss man sagen dass die zahlen
nicht ganz vergleichbar sind weil wir
ihm früher auch weniger getestet haben
wir haben nicht ganz so viel getestet
wie heute wir schauen heute genauer hin
wir sind sensitiver das heißt die zahl
der 6000 die wir heute haben ist ein
besseres abbild der tatsächlichen
infektionszahlen als es im frühjahr war
es gibt immer eine dunkelziffer
und die dunkelziffer kennen wenig genau
sie ist aber jetzt im herbst geringer
als sie ihm früher gewesen ist und das
andere was wir natürlich gelernt haben
wir haben wirklich sehr sehr viel über
das virus gelernt und wir haben
inzwischen einen relativ guten
werkzeugkasten mit dem wir die
ausbreitung des virus auch wirklich
verhindern können und eindämmen können
das ist die aufgabe die uns eben alle
umtreiben die nächsten monaten noch
wenn wir jetzt schon 6000 neuinfektionen
am tag haben was passierte dann im
winter im dezember januar februar wenn
wir nicht die maßnahmen verschärfen
werden die zahlen weiter hoch gehen
ich kann keine prognose abgeben wo sie
hingehen aber sie werden sicher wenn er
so weiter geht die 10.000 überschreiten
aber wir wollen das verhindern und ich
bin auch nach wie vor der ansicht dass
wir das auch noch schaffen können
die bundeskanzlerin hat sich mit den 16
ministerpräsidenten getroffen und sie
haben ein maßnahmenbündel beschlossen
bei dem die kanzlerin gesagt haben soll
das reicht nicht aus das unheil zu
verhindern das klingt nicht wirklich
beruhigend wie sehen sie das
ich denke es ist sehr wichtig dass wir
in deutschland einheitliche maßnahmen
haben das ist sehr wichtig weil
natürlich die bereitschaft der
bevölkerung diese maßnahmen mitzutragen
sehr stark davon abhängt dass sie
nachvollziehbar sind und einheitlich
sind die maßnahmen die getroffen wurden
heißen dass wir noch mehr masken pflicht
haben ab einem geringeren grenzwert die
maßnahmen die getroffen wurden heißen
dass sich weniger menschen abends nach
sperrstunden in restaurants und kneipen
treffen
sie reduzieren tatsächlich die werden
dazu führen dass die zahlen runter gehen
wenn sich die menschen natürlich daran
halten
aber wir müssen vor allem dafür sorge
tragen dass sie auch eingehalten werden
und ich sage es nochmal die müssen auch
möglichst einheitlich sein
der rahmen muss einheitlich sein und
dann muss man regional natürlich noch
maßnahmen verschärfen wenn sie so wie
die kanzlerin ist das nicht ausreichend
fehlt ihnen was also mir fehlt
verbindlichkeit
es gibt immer noch einige von den
maßnahmen das sind empfehlungen
ich würde mir wünschen dass diese
empfehlung und auch verpflichtend dann
durchgeführt werden also zum beispiel
das tragen von masken sollte prinzipiell
dann verpflichtend sein das ist aber
realen fußgängerzonen in deutschland zum
beispiel ein es geht darum wer vom
robert-koch-institut wir empfehlen ja
das masken tragen bei bestimmten
umständen und die politische aufgabe ist
es dann aus den empfehlungen des robert
koch instituts unter anderem impfpflicht
aussagen zu treffen und es gibt umstände
wo masken eine große rolle spielen das
ist hauptsächlich in innenräumen und in
innenräumen empfehlen wir das tragen von
masken und dann wünschen wir uns
natürlich dass die entscheider dieses
massen kann dann verpflichtend um sie
zum beispiel in den büros zum beispiel
in büros abhängig von der anzahl der
menschen die dort drin sitzen und
abhängig von der größe der büros noch
ein zitat dieses mal der bayerische
ministerpräsident
wir sind dem zweiten lockdown viel näher
als wir das wahrhaben wollen wirklich
das vermag ich nicht zu sagen also ich
habe nach wie vor die den optimismus
dass wir das verhindern können
ich weiß dass wir das können ich weiß
dass wir es können weil wir werkzeuge
haben die wir einsetzen können die frage
ist setzen wir sie ein
und wie tragen wir sorge dafür dass sie
eingesetzt werden aber machbar ist das
noch ja besonders umstritten sind die
sogenannten beherbergungs verbote sind
die sinnvoll bringt das wirklich was
also ein virus die dieses virus
verbreitet sich darüber dass sich
menschen begegnen nahe zusammen kommen
längere zeit zusammen kommen
einer von den menschen wäre infiziert
dann wird er das virus über die atemwege
ausscheiden und dann besteht die chance
dass andere menschen angesteckt werden
und das heißt die weniger menschen sich
dann mobil wohin bewegen desto geringer
ist die chance dass sie andere ansteckt
mobilität ist einer der treiber
natürlich dieser pannen in dem
zusammenhang ganz interessant die
kanzlerin hatte zum treffen mit den
ministerpräsidenten an experten geladen
von helmholtz zentrum und der soll wir
waren ja nicht dabei
der soll geraten haben man müsse die
risikogebiete abriegeln also ich sag mal
was das heißt das würde bedeuten berlin
münchen köln müssten abgeriegelt werden
da dürfte dann keiner raus und keiner
rein
ist das etwas wo sie sagen ja könnte
sinnvoll sein und ist das überhaupt
denkbar in der gesellschaft wieder
bundesrepublik vor neun monaten noch
habe ich in einem ähnlichen interview
gesagt dass ich mir das nicht vorstellen
kann inzwischen kann ich mir vorstellen
dass solche maßnahmen durchgeführt
wurden der hintergrund ist wieder der
gleiche den ich eben nannte mobilität
ist ein treiber dieser pandemie ob das
wirklich geschehen wird ob die politik
sich dazu entscheiden wird das wird man
sehen
bisher sind wir in deutschland
vergleichsweise gut durch diese pandemie
gekommen vor allem stehen wir sehr gut
da wenn wir uns mal mit nachbarländern
vergleichen wie dem niederlande wie
frankreich spanien italien und auch die
usa natürlich warum sind wir so gut
durch die partner medical das ist eine
frage die wir wirklich täglich gestellt
bekommen von vielen kollegen aus dem
ausland wir sind sehr intensiv mit
kollegen unterwegs weil wir auch viel
lernen von anderen kollegen und sie
lernen von uns also es gibt viele gründe
es gibt nicht den einen grund ein
wichtiger grund ist sicher dass wir eine
gute governance haben in unserem staat
wir haben ein - das bedeutet wir sind in
einem staat wo wir gut regiert werden ja
das kann man ja sie haben recht das ist
der bessere ausdruck
also wir sind gut regiert wir haben ein
hohes vertrauen in die institutionen das
ist sicher ein punkt den man haben muss
es gibt immer wieder befragungen die das
auch belegen 80 prozent der deutschen
sind mit den maßnahmen insgesamt
zufrieden tragen sie mit das heute
sicher auch wir haben natürlich auch
institutionen wie das
robert-koch-institut die nach bestem
wissen und gewissen fachlich
entscheidungen treffen und empfehlungen
herausgeben und diese empfehlungen sind
fachlich begründet und mit einem
größtmöglichen maß auch von fachlicher
unabhängigkeit und wenn diese
empfehlungen dann so herausgegeben
werden
dann ist es natürlich schön wenn sich
dann andere nach diesen empfehlungen
auch richten und sie dann umsetzen
und ich glaube dass ich versuchen zu
verstehen was sie da gerade sagen man
lässt sie ihre arbeit machen und die
politik hört auch noch auf see und in
anderen ländern ist das nicht der fall
usa vermute ich mal gehört dazu aber
vielleicht auch das eine oder andere
europäische land
es ist tatsächlich so ich glaube dass
das die die zuhörer auch wissen dass in
den usa tatsächlich die einflussnahme
auf das cdc durchaus gegeben war
und das ist natürlich kein guter
einfluss denn die fachlichkeit muss im
vordergrund stehen
was die politische entscheidungsträger
dann daraus macht ist eine ganz andere
frage aber der entscheidende punkt ist
dass die die fakten nach bestem wissen
und gewissen aufgearbeitet werden müssen
an die öffentlichkeit gekommen
und das sind dann eben nur empfehlungen
die umsetzung liegt in der hand der
politiker damals kurz noch erklären des
cdc ist quasi das robert koch institut
der usa das für seuchenbekämpfung
zuständige institut es gibt ja so eine
art von logik die einleuchtend klingt
zunächst einmal harte maßnahmen führen
zu guten ergebnissen aber wenn ich jetzt
mal hinschauen zu ländern wie frankreich
und spanien
die hatten viel viel striktere maßnahmen
implementiert als wir das in deutschland
gemacht haben
aber ohne erfolg im gegenteil haben sie
dann erklären dafür also es gibt ein
phänomen wenn man zu harte maßnahmen
fährt dann ist natürlich die akzeptanz
der bevölkerung die wird schneller
schwinden
und wir haben in deutschland ja keinen
richtigen lockdown gehabt dem früher
sondern wir hatten ja kontakt
beschränkungen aber das freie leben weil
er nicht eingeschränkt und in anderen
ländern war das stärker so ich glaube
das ist ein wichtiger punkt wir müssen
daran denken dass wir ja noch viele
monate diese pandemie bewältigen wir
müssen mit mit den maßnahmen
sorgfältiger umgehen ich glaube das ist
zu harte maßnahmen die akzeptanz der
bevölkerung kurzfristig dann nicht mehr
gelten lässt also das ist sicher ein
punkt ein anderer punkt ist aber auch
den dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen wir
haben natürlich in deutschland schon
noch immer ein sehr stabiles und
intensives gesundheitssystem was sehr
viele ressourcen hat und auch
leistungsfähiger ist und es gibt ein
system in deutschland das nicht in allen
ländern so gut funktioniert das ist der
so genannte öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst der ist zwar auch in
deutschland in den letzten jahrzehnten
runter gespart worden aber er ist immer
noch leistungsfähiger als in vielen
anderen
das robert-koch-institut hat einen
großen anteil daran dass wir bisher so
gut durch die krise kamen
trotzdem haben sie fehler gemacht ja
diese frage wird immer wieder gestellt
ich kann dazu nur sagen dass wir
kontinuierlich und besprechen das wir
analysieren das hier mit experten aus
dem ausland aus anderen bereichen reden
wir versuchen fehler so gut wie möglich
zu vermeiden und wir haben es bisher
ziemlich gut hinbekommen also den
fehlern gehört schon dass sie sehr lange
von der maske abgeraten haben und nicht
zu geraten haben das sehe ich nicht als
fehler an ich kann ihnen erklären warum
zu beginn dieser pandemie hatten wir
bestimmte kenntnisse über das virus
nicht und ein punkt war der den wir
nicht wussten dass das virus schon
ausgeschieden wird bei patienten bevor
sie symptome bekommen unsere denkweise
war die wenn menschen symptomatisch
werden das sagen wir heute noch dann
mögen sie bitte zu hause bleiben ihren
arzt anrufen und dann regelt wie es
weitergeht aber sie sollen eben zu hause
bleiben damit sie niemand an steckt das
ist das ganz große prinzip dahinter wenn
man dann zu hause ist dann geht man ja
nicht raus und dann steckt man niemand
anderen an
wir hatten damals gesagt symptomatischen
patienten die sollen dann auch masken
tragen
aber wir wussten nicht dass schon vor
dem turm diese viren ausgeschieden
werden also ist das klar wurde war klar
dass masken eine größere wirkung haben
dass der eine grund der andere grund ist
der wir wissen inzwischen dass das virus
auch über eurozone übertragen wird also
nicht nur über tröpfchen wie wir das
früher dachten und dadurch ist die
wirksamkeit der massen natürlich noch
höher
das heißt also ich betrachte das nicht
als fehler sondern wir haben damals nach
dem besten stand des wissens eine
empfehlung herausgeben die haben wir
dann korrigiert angepasst lassen sie uns
mal auf die argumente der kritiker
kicken ich beginne mal mit dem chef der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
gassen der hat gesagt immer nur auf die
zahl der neuinfektionen zu starren das
führt zu falschen alarmismus hat
erreicht ja da hat er recht aber der
start der nur auf die zahlen das ist
eine perspektiven frage das
robert-koch-institut start nicht nur auf
die zahlen
wir haben eine menge von parametern
übrigens gibt es ja ein
situationsbericht den wir ja wirklich
wird seit januar glaube schon
täglich auf unsere website stellen
da sind ja ganz viele zahlen drin da
sind zahlen trends über die zeit da sind
die zahlen wie viele tests werden
durchgeführt wie viel dieser test sind
positiv die prozentual sein
die inzidenz da sind karten drin wie
viele landkreise bestimmte institution
aber da sind sogar daten drin zu den
belegung von intensivbetten also wenn
herr gassen das so sieht vielleicht
schaut er nur auf die zahlen aber da
müssen sie ihn selber fragen wen er
damit dann schauen wir jetzt mal auf
andere zahlen
im frühjahr hatten wir bei 5000 euro
infektionen pro tag über 200 tote am tag
heute haben wir im schnitt 16 tote am
tag
rechtfertigt das nach wie vor diese
strikten maßnahmen mit all den
kollateralschäden ja also ich würde ihn
erklären warum die so hohe zahlen hatten
im frühjahr dort haben wir weniger
getestet und haben weniger sensitive
getestet das heißt die anzahl derjenigen
die positiv getestet wurden und die
verstorben waren waren höher als
momentan
und wir haben damals am anfang ist nicht
geschafft so intensiv die das virus aus
den entsprechenden gruppen wie wir das
sagen herauszuhalten also was
krankenhäusern pflegeheimen und dadurch
werden die menschen infiziert wie das
größte risiko schwer zu erkranken und
auch zu versterben
das ist die begründung für die hohen
todesraten und wir haben vielleicht
haben wir inzwischen ja auch einiges
gelernt wie man erkrankte behandeln muss
ja dass das kommt genau jetzt und wir
können auch ein bisschen besser
behandeln jetzt also die ärzte können
tatsächlich patient noch besser
behandelt das ist auch korrekt aber der
entscheidende punkt ist momentan der das
ist ja immer ein app ideologisches
geschehen das hängt von vielen faktoren
ab damals wurde es reingetragen durch
junge menschen hauptsächlich aus dem
ausland skiurlaub und so und in die
familie und diese altersheim getragen
heute ist es breit in deutschland
vorhanden
man weiß dass das virus da ist und jetzt
stecken sich zur zeit sehr viele junge
leute an wir hatten mal eine zeit da war
das durchschnittsalter der fälle
52 jetzt liegt es bei mitte dreißig
glaube ich und die jungen leute werden
nicht so schwer erkrankt aber wir werden
und das ist immer wieder diese glaube
ich ein richtiger denkfehler
die zahlen die wir uns anschauen nehmen
wir den meldezahlen der guckt wie immer
in die vergangenheit
wir gucken drin was von der woche etwa
passiert ist bis die zahl der gemeldeten
ankommt ist ein blind patagonia und
sagen wir eine woche und wir schauen
nicht in die zukunft und wir werden
sehen dass die zahl der schwererkrankten
und derjenigen die todesraten die werden
auch dann steigen weil eben wieder mehr
ältere menschen infiziert wenn das heißt
also wir wissen dass wir in die
vergangenheit schauen wir wissen nicht
genau was vorne kommt aber wissen wenn
wir heute nur maßnahmen betreffen dann
sehen wir den effekt der maßnahme sind
zwei drei wochen noch mal ein blick auf
die etwas radikaleren kritiker die sagen
die krone epidemie das ist in
wirklichkeit sowie eine schwere grippe
epidemie da gibt es auch ein paar
argumente der winter 2017/18 25.000
grippetote bisher in deutschland noch
nicht mal 10.000 tote durch corona das
schon argument also das ist ein echter
trugschluss
bei der grippe ist das problem dass die
grippewelle jedes jahr ein bisschen
anders aus hat und diese grippewelle die
sie beschreiben ist wirklich eine
schwere grippewelle gewesen 25.000 tote
haben wir geschätzt dass daran gestorben
das ist eine schwere grippewelle die
anderen grippewellen sind aber im
schnitt deutlich geringer wir haben am
robert-koch-institut ein paar analyse
tools entwickelt über den letzten jahr
wir haben das sehr genau verglichen
wir wissen das kogit 19 zu deutlich mehr
todesfällen führt wir haben so bestimmte
zu den systemen entweder das
überwachungssysteme wir haben die
verglichen die letzten fünf jahre grippe
und dieses jahr wird wir sehen dass die
sterberaten 22 prozent von den menschen
sind die im krankenhaus eingeliefert
sind bykow wird zwölf prozent bei denen
die mit krippe immer intensivmedizinisch
behandelt wurden wir sehen das kogit
dazu führt dass dort menschen deutlich
länger in krankenhäusern liegt auch
deutlich länger beatmet werden intensiv
intensivbetten liegen und wir sehen auch
dass es deutlich mehr langzeitfolge
schäden gibt durch das komitee ioc das
heißt also man kann das vergleichen aber
im vergleich kommt ganz klar heraus dass
coop 19
eine deutliche und krankheitslast was
ist mit dem vorwurf bei uns würden
menschen als corona tote gewertet die in
wirklichkeit an anderen dingen gestorben
sind
beispielsweise warum unterscheiden sie
nicht deutlich zwischen menschen die
wirklich an cholera gestorben sind und
denen die nur mit corona gestorben sind
also erstmals ja also dieser vorwurf
wurde am anfang gemacht unter anderem
von pathologen die ihn selber dann
hinterher entkräftet haben weil sie
nämlich dann ihre daten publiziert haben
nach den daten die von der bestimmten
arbeitsgruppe in deutschland publiziert
werden sind 86 prozent derjenigen die
von gesundheitsämtern nicht vom
robert-koch-institut als todesfall
infolge von profit diagnostiziert wurden
86 prozent der ihnen sind auch wirklich
an cupid verstorben das ist eine arbeit
die vor ein paar monaten im deutschen
ärzteblatt erschienen ist das heißt also
das ist eine hohe zahl die ankowitsch
haben wir können das nicht unterscheiden
weil wir bekommen wir die meldezahlen
von den gesundheitsämtern noch den fall
definition und die werden uns gegeben
und wir haben eine bestimmte gesetzliche
verpflichtung laut
infektionsschutzgesetz wir definieren
fälle und dann bringen wir die daten so
raus jetzt werden natürlich untersuchung
gemacht wie viel der menschen die die
reduzierte von gestorbenen tatsächlich
an co wird gestorben sind ich möchte
aber noch ergänzen
es gibt inzwischen die erkenntnisse dass
das virus ja nicht nur
lungenentzündungen macht sondern gerade
dazu führt dass auch in den gefäßen
schäden entstehen so dass menschen
schlaganfälle herzinfarkte in folge des
virus geschehen die vielleicht überhaupt
nicht als ko wird erkannt werden so dass
ich gehe sogar davon aus dass eigentlich
mehr todesfälle haben in wirklichkeit
als die die wir über die meldezahlen sie
hervorgerufen durch ko wittwer
freiheitsrechte der menschen einschränkt
wäre für wirtschaftlichen lockdown sorgt
er muss das gut begründen nur hat diese
begründung im lauf der zeit immer wieder
gewechselt am anfang hieß es wir müssen
auch die verdoppelung zahlen 8
dann hieß es wir müssen darauf achten
dass die intensivbetten nicht dass die
ausreichen und dann hieß es wir müssen
zehntausende von toten verhindern also
zumindest bisher ist ja all das nicht
eingetreten was also ist das eigentliche
ziel dessen was wir da machen
also was sie sagen doch ist aus meiner
sicht eine wahrnehmung also ich glaube
nicht oder ich kann wie gesagt es war
zumindest nicht das ziel des
robert-koch-instituts immer auf einen
dieser parameter zu schauen
ich bin sicher dass das nicht immer
optimal kommuniziert wurde aber es war
nie das ziel nur eine dieser maße das
wichtigste für uns ist natürlich wir
wollen möglichst wenig menschen in
deutschland sehen die sich mit dem virus
infizieren und schwer daran erkranken
und die anderen dinge die sie ansprechen
sind ja alles nur beschreibungen von
diesem von diesem ausgang also wir
wollen möglichst wenig menschen die
schwer an kuwait erkannten und ins
krankenhaus kommen intensivmedizinisch
behandelt werden und das andere sind
indikatoren mit denen wir das dann
begleiten können und so für
intervenieren
hier wird noch gerne ein bisschen was
erfahren über die personen die uns da
durch diese krise steuert also virologen
des rk ii
das ist ja etwas was normalerweise
wirklich im schatten der öffentlichkeit
ist plötzlich sind sie zu einer person
des öffentlichen lebens geworden
bekannte als viele politiker fühlt sich
wohl in dieser rolle
diese rolle hat sich geändert
tatsächlich es gibt ein paar schöne
begleiterscheinung wenn man prominent
ist man kriegt viel schulterklopfen es
gibt sehr viele menschen die sich bei
uns bedanken
beim robert-koch-institut natürlich hat
man eine große sichtbarkeit
es hat aber auch schattenseiten die
beleidigungen und bedrohungen kriegen
sie hass mails trauen natürlich das ist
ja leider offensichtlich ein
gesellschaftlicher zustand denn viele
prominente ertragen müssen aber
hauptsächlich kriegen die leider meine
mitarbeiterin koch institut ab die dann
damit umgehen müssen
das ist eine ungute neben erscheinen
aber ansonsten der entscheidende punkt
ist der wir müssen und wir machen und
den job so gut wir das können und der
entscheidende punkt warum ich überhaupt
in der öffentlichkeit versuche zumindest
das fachwissen so gut wie möglich weiter
zu geben ist dass ich exzellente
mitarbeiter in mitarbeiter haben die
diese dinge ja alle mit mir zusammen
durch denken das ist ja nicht meine
persönliche expertise sondern das ist ja
die kumulation von all den daten und
gesprächen und analysen die wm aus
durchführen
und das ist eben der punkt es sind eben
nicht nur für urologen ich selber bin
noch nicht wieder logge ich bin
mikrobiologe und thc
es heißt ja die kanzlerin die hört auf
die wissenschaft mir häufig holt sie
denn ihren rat einreden sie um ihr habe
ich einmal die woche
also wir sind ja eine nachgeordnete
behörde des gesundheitsministeriums das
heißt also wir beraten direkt den
gesundheitsminister das ist unsere
aufgabe und interaktion mit dem
kanzleramt am wir ab und an aber das ist
sicher nicht regelmäßig dann komme ich
auf diese frage zurück wie kommt das
dass ein von der ausbildung her tierarzt
professor für tiermedizin uns menschen
in deutschland durch diese pandemie ist
daher das ist ja eine position die wird
ausgeschrieben und da steht drin
bewerbungsprofil man muss entweder
biologe tierarzt oder humanmediziner
sein und dann bewirbt man sich und dann
in dem fall hat man mich ausgewählt die
gründe dafür kenne ich nicht aber es war
nicht zu bescheiden sein ich glaube
nämlich selber dass man ihn so pandemien
ganz schön viel von tiermedizinern
lernen kann weil die haben im normalfall
vielmehr pandemien als wir gott sei dank
beim menschen haben ja also es ist
tatsächlich so dass die ausbildung wenn
sie die die die medizinische ausbildung
anschauen wir haben ein deutlich höheres
niveau wenn es um infektionskrankheiten
geht das hängt einfach damit zusammen
dass infektionskrankheiten im bereich
der tiermedizin eine riesige rolle
spielen und es gibt einen zweiten punkt
wir sind in hohem maße so genannte
population mediziner also wir betrachten
nicht nur einzelne patienten sondern wir
betrachten immer gruppen das heißt sie
versucht es mal zu überschätzen
übersetzen sie müssen nicht unbedingt
die einzelne kuh retten aber die herde
soll harmonisiert werden dass offenen
punkt gebracht wir haben dort wirklich
extrem gute ausbildung das heißt wir
haben auch in der epidemiologie extrem
gute ausbildung insofern sind die ärzte
eigentlich finde ich persönlich sehr
sehr gut geeignet dazu so einen job zu
übernehmen wie sie ist übrigens nicht
das einzige publik als institute
weltweiter sein
die alte chinesische csi wird auch von
einem team zu leiten so tritt entweder
in die fußstapfen seines vaters oder
nachts genaue gegenteil
ihr vater war tiermediziner hatten so
ein gutes verhältnis
ja mein vater ist ein ganz wichtige
person für mich immer gewesen
er war glaube ich mal vier jahre in
russischer kriegsgefangenschaft ja das
ist natürlich ein prägendes ereignis
ganz klar ich bin einer der generation
der letzten nachfolge generation der
kriegsgeneration prägt einen
selbstverständlich mein vater und auch
der großvater war irgendwie arzt man hat
bestimmte bodenständige erziehungs wie
soll ich das sagen da werden wir sie mir
das vorstelle ja wir sind früher alle
kinder sind wir immer mit meinem vater
durch die gegend gefahren ja wir wollen
vielen tier stellen und sind dort
aufgewachsen
ihr spezialgebiet als tiermediziner war
dann die sogenannten zoonosen das muss
man glaube ich erklären das sind
krankheiten die von tieren auf menschen
überspringen und damit kommen wir zurück
zum corona virus wissen wir denn
inzwischen wirklich wie dieses corona
virus entstanden ist da kann man nur da
hat man wahrscheinlich keiten also ist
das höchste wahrscheinlich anzunehmende
szenario ist dass eine fledermaus dieses
jahres getragen hat versteht aber oft
deutsch kroner während und dann ist es
irgendwie auf den menschen
übergesprungen
entweder durch einatmen von zum beispiel
code von fledermäusen oder dadurch dass
es dass man vielleicht die auch verzehrt
hat oder dass sie über den zwischen wird
gekommen sind der infiziert wurde
da gibt es plausibilitäten aber auch für
das jemals beweisen können dass vom mag
ich nicht zu sagen können sie denn
wirklich ausschließen dass dieses virus
in einem labor zum beispiel in vivo hahn
entstanden ist und dann absichtlich oder
unabsichtlich verbreitet wurde
das kann man nie ganz ausschließen also
ich kann mir ist sehr schwer vorstellen
dass wirklich zu beweisen wo das virus
er kommt es sei denn man würde genau
diesen virenstamm in einem tier finden
aber die chance ist natürlich sehr
gering es gibt ja millionen von
fledermäusen
sie haben es ja schon ein bisschen
angedeutet also wahrscheinlich hat die
art und weise wie man in china mit
tieren umgeht schon was mit der
entstehung dieser zur rose zu tun dass
die enge nähe auf diesen zielmärkten die
tatsache dass man in china dinge ist
geboren bei uns nie essen würde wie
schätzen sie das ein
ja wir wissen dass wir in den letzten
jahrzehnten wird also der mensch ist in
den letzten jahrzehnten immer weiter
eingedrungen in bestimmte umwelt früher
nicht wahr
die interaktion zwischen wildtier und
menschen würden immer intensiver das
nahrungs verhalten spielt natürlich eine
rolle aber auch der handel der handel
mit bestimmten exotischen tieren spielt
eine rolle
wir müssen vielmehr von der un
durchgesetzte konvention wirklich
durchgezogen werden wir müssen illegalen
tierhandel verbieten natürlich sollten
sich auch die ernährungsgewohnheiten der
menschen ändern ganz gesagt welche rolle
spielt die massentierhaltung bei 2000
bei 2000 spielt sie keine so große rolle
weil die massentierhaltung also die
konventionelle tierhaltung dazu führt
dass man in der regel relativ gute bio
sicherheits containments hat also das
heißt dass tiere in stallungen gehalten
werden und dort darauf geachtet wird
dass nichts rein kommt oder rauskommt
aber der entscheidende punkt und wenn
sie das anschauen über die letzten
jahrzehnte
rund zwei drittel aller
infektionskrankheiten die zum menschen
übergehen kommen vom tier da kommt
natürlich die mehrheit von wildtieren
auf den menschen
lassen sie uns mal ein blick nach vorne
richten kann es sein dass dieses virus
nie wieder verschwinden wird ja also ich
persönlich gehe davon aus dass wir uns
nie mehr verschwinden wird die frage ist
es wird sich anpassen es wird
hoffentlich weniger krank machen und wir
werden mit dem virus leben
wir haben ja eine reihe von
schnupfenviren es gibt ja unter anderem
vier corona wären die nur leichten
schnupfen machen wir wissen von einem
dieser viren dass es sich im laufe von
mehreren hundert jahren zu einem relativ
harmlosen schnupfen virus entwickelt hat
und ich gehe davon aus dass das mit
diesem virus auch der fall sein wird
was heißt das dann wenn sie sagen wir
werden lernen müssen mit diesem virus zu
leben heißt das unter umständen corona
beschränkung maßnahmen masken über jahre
ich denke dass wir mit der einführung
von impfstoffen in
entscheidendes werkzeug bekommen mit dem
wir die krankheit beherrschen und die
krankheitslast so reduzieren können dass
wir wieder zu einem leben dazu kommen
wie es vor kroner war
ich hoffe allerdings auch dass von einer
reihe von dingen gelernt haben die
vielleicht so gut für die umwelt als
auch für andere ökologische aspekte
weiter so gehalten werden unabhängig
davon ob es dieses virus gibt oder nicht
denn wir haben ja glaub ich auch viel
gelernt wie wir unsere gesellschaft auch
besser in die zukunft führen können in
der zeit wie beurteilen sie die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines impfstoffes
innerhalb der nächsten sechs monate
also wir gehen alle davon aus dass im
nächsten jahr impfstoffe zugelassen
werden wir wissen nicht genau wie die
wirken wie gut die wirken was die
bewirken aber ich bin sehr optimistisch
dass ihm stoffe gibt ja das war völlig
persönlich halte mit professor lothar
wähler
herzlichen dank an sie und an sie zu
hause bleiben sie gesund